this holiday weekend is without one
popular tradition for millions of people
in California all beaches in the state
are closed as part of governor Gavin
Newsom is effort to control the rising
kovat 19 infection rates there Kovach
cases are surging in dozens of states
across the country bringing the total
number to more than two point seven nine
million and the death toll is rising to
more than a hundred and twenty nine
thousand Michael George is in Rockaway
Beach New York Michael good morning to
you chef's good morning thousands are
expected to pack Rockaway Beach here
later today and they'll be greeted by
city workers reminding them that masks
are required on the sand and the
boardwalk it's a fourth of July unlike
any other with the corona virus now at
an all-time high across the US and
health experts blaming the decision by
States to reopen early and many openly
defying safety rules fourth of July
fireworks may be loaded and ready to
launch on the National Mall in
Washington DC but in the nation's fight
against the corona virus there's little
to celebrate right now we are heading a
million miles per hour in the wrong
direction new US cases in a single day
hit record highs Wednesday Thursday and
again Friday when more than 57,000 new
cases were reported showing the pandemic
is winning it's absolutely the saddest
thing the most unnecessary situation
that we're finding ourselves in and it's
behaviorally driven cases in 37 states
have risen since the economy started to
reopen in Arizona 50 Phoenix
firefighters tested positive another 40
are in quarantine in Florida a state
where leaders resisted safety measures
10,000 new cases were recorded Thursday
alone but now with some Florida
hospitals stretched to the limits caring
for patients miami-dade county put in a
10:00 p.m. - sunrise curfew until
further notice there and in other parts
of the nation popular beaches will be
closed this holiday weekend
we all wish we could have the beaches
open but it's just not the right thing
to do Malibu California mayor Karen
Ferrer is keeping an eye on surfers
after the governor ordered most southern
California beaches closed again
since they reopened three weeks ago
there's been a surge in cases including
some lifeguards and Galveston Texas
closed beaches fearing crowds would pour
in from Houston where one out of four
people tested positive primarily we're
seeing a surge in young people who are
really just not paying any regard to the
risk of this a frustration for health
professionals do we really have to say
hashtag don't kill grandma people have
to realize there are consequences to
getting infected and spreading it to
people who are vulnerable they can die
many cities now require masks in Santa
Monica anyone not wearing one could end
up with a ticket and Chicago is joining
several areas including New York New
Jersey and Connecticut requiring
visitors from hotspot states quarantine
for 14 days upon arrival we're gonna do
everything that we can to keep members
of the public safe that includes
visitors from California and some aren't
happy about it I'm not gonna go
somewhere that's a full quarantine like
once you set foot on that ground like
you have to quarantine that's what that
means like I don't wanna have to go
through that and here in New York one of
the parts of the country with the lowest
infection rates leaders are alarmed
about what's happening in the rest of
the US indoor dining was supposed to
start again on Monday now that's been
postponed indefinitely
Michelle Michael better to be safe than
sorry thank you so much